so unlike some of the other races for
the game of the year candidates I think
this one was pretty cut and dry that
hearthstone just really won over
everybody in our office you're so shall
be my I remember our discussion about
this basically it came down to is ha
stone you know really a good mobile
experience because everyone also plays
ha stone and PC and it came down to
really ha stone in threes and a lot of
people arguing threes was that perfect
sort of mobile game which you can just
play it in verse on a train or bus her
stone is so much better on like ipad i
feel like the definitive hearthstone
experience is a mobile experience cuz
it's so much easier and more fluid to
just touch and go and stuff like that so
yeah and i think when we're talking
about what's the best game on a given
platform I don't know that it's that
important that it seems like a mobile
game necessarily right it's the best
game that's their threes is a great
mobile game but hearthstone is sort of
the broader experience like the grander
game and I think people inevitably like
that's why they chose it right it's a
much more engrossing game to play
regardless if it feels a great mobile
time even though it's free to play it
doesn't feel like a cash-in it's
something that does it rewards you or
the amount of time that you put into it
if you want to spend some cash till
speed up you never have to pay to play
the game I mean it's very successful at
making you want to spend money i know
it's free to play and a lot of people
like don't you know want that experience
without having to pay for it but i think
it does a very good job of rewarding you
if you do not just like getting ahead
but like those cards like so many people
are just obsessed with getting all of
those
hearthstone also as that a multiplayer
experience I mean coming from Blizzard
they know how to do an online game
obviously but this is such smaller scope
that they've done this with a really
small team but it's just as exciting
it's so much fun when you're playing
against a real person because you're
matched up randomly against people you
don't know when you're gonna rank up
maybe they have better cards to do but
even when they have been our cards even
when people have thrown out a legendary
every now and then I'm able to take them
over with my my free deck that I haven't
spent as much time at but oh my god is
so satisfying to crush somebody
you